[Music]
this morning on halloween weekend a
journey through the history of magic
with david copperfield the most
successful commercial magician of all
time is more than four decades into his
career and still putting on shows every
day
this week he released a new book david
copperfield's history of magic which
takes readers for the legendary figures
of illusion the book is published by
simon schuster division of viacom cbs
but we spoke with copperfield about much
more magic family
the past
and future
the magic of david copperfield david
copperfield began taking his place in
magic history in the late 1970s with a
television special and went on to do a
series of prime time events on cbs
including making the statue of liberty
disappear
[Applause]
[Music]
walking through the great wall of china
and getting cut in half by the death saw
[Music]
i remember as a kid watching those david
copperfield specials
when you watch them today what do you
think
sometimes i cringe a little bit and
sometimes i like it
there wasn't much that i would have
changed about it there's a lot of bad
haircuts a lot of big collars and a lot
of things that you know you wish i could
do that but there's certain things that
i think have have really made a mark and
those ones i'm kind of proud of his new
book david copperfield's history of
magic is a personal journey chronicling
centuries of astonishing performances
when did magic start
we think in the egyptian times
in china there's roots of in china
that go back way back the first book
ever to be written on magic itself is
that book right there the discovery of
witchcraft 1584. copperfield's book is
an extension of the private gallery that
he's been curating for decades
just off the famed las vegas strip the
outside of the international museum and
library of the conjuring arts is
disguised as an homage to corby's the
haberdashery his father owned when
copperfield was growing up as david
cotkin in new jersey
[Music]
beyond the facade priceless magical
tools used by the men and women
copperfield has idolized since he was a
child among the legends featured in the
book
the great robert hudan robert hudan
we call the father of modern magic
because he took people
magicians off the street and put it in a
respectable setting sudan himself was
really invented the first smart home the
door to his house open as a magic effect
come over here put your back against the
wall please
grab the bottom of the tie and pull in
effect not unlike the one copperfield
incorporated at the secret entrance to
his collection follow me
on the other side of the would-be
dressing room are more than 80 000
pieces of magic memorabilia this place
has expanded how much in the last few
years i think five times usually only
open to researchers and fellow magicians
copperfield gave us a private tour fair
props
abbott's props revealing these
one-of-a-kind exhibits this is robert
albo demonstrating the method of this
well you can't show that
including the famous straight jacket
worn by eric weiss who you know as harry
houdini the greatest escape artist of
all time
[Music]
a display is dedicated to adelaide
hermann the queen of magic who had a
legendary career catching bullets
the first giant of magic copperfield was
able to meet and learn from in person
was channing pollock the cameras shoot
this in slow motion and yet
and yet
he dazzled audiences by pulling doves
seemingly out of nowhere
when you watch pollock's videos
it's effortless
it's
really really beautiful and lots of
people do
that kind of act
but
nothing's quite like that
it's like he's not even trying no and
not trying and does he is
[Music]
that's magic so we have a
comic
they're all
empty magic as copperfield writes about
and practices is not supernatural all
the different colors
it is the art of appearing to be
nice what
spa though it can still be hard to
figure out the difference
how does that happen like when he asked
us to name any card from a full deck say
that loud ten of diamonds okay watch
what
no freaking
way come on wait a minute
it's magic
how does that happen
i i said how did how does that happen
i would like to know please explain
no one will
if you want to know where copperfield's
obsession came from
go back to his childhood
his latest show is heavy on family
copperfield's dad gave up his stage and
screen dreams to nourish his son's goals
if your dad had not given up his acting
career would we be sitting here today
well no one's ever asked me that before
i think we would
because i i think he would have still
encouraged me to follow my dreams
because he would have had his dream too
you know i think
yeah wow that's
that's great
okay you're turning into oprah you're
gonna start making me cry
i don't mean to make this a therapy
session yeah do it do it this is good i
like it
i need some
today's copperfield performances at the
mgm grand in las vegas are different
more interaction with the audience
more focus on the next generation i love
when magic is pushed into new directions
what's the best kind of magic the magic
that inspires
magic that can move the world forward
i do lots of magic in my show that
prototypes the future that shows what
the possible future accomplishments of
humanity
is you know
i hope there's a kid in the audience
that's going to see that and have the
wherewithal to make it real
now more than 40 years into his career
still works every single day does
multiple shows most days which is pretty
remarkable and the show is it's how it's
evolved it's it's almost like
copperfield half magician half stand-up
comedian yeah right he's out in the
audience doing these shows he looks
great and i was with you i want to know
how you do that i yes i know i still
can't figure it out i know i wanted to
if i were you i would have wanted to
pinch myself because you know we all
grew up with him yeah and his specials
yeah and he still looks as young as
i said it still looks pretty it's magic
yes it is magic different kind of magic
but magic nonetheless